[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du grand jt des
territoires sur tv5monde et sur vos
chaînes locales et régionales de la tnt
avant toutes choses permettez moi de
vous présenter au nom de toute l'équipe
du grand jt une belle et heureuse année
2022 nous en avons tous besoin voici
donc les titres de ce tout premier grand
jt de la bulle
il se peut que vous en ayez eu un sou
sapin de noël je parle du jeu de société
dont le succès ne se dément pas année
après année que vous allez le voir dans
un sujet à suivre de nos confrères de
wimereux tv la chaîne de la voix du nord
voici le temps de la galette des rois
avaient donc aux gourmands dans ce
journal tv 60,18 vous fera découvrir les
secrets de la meilleure galette des
yvelines à ce qu'il paraît et puis le
temps n'a pas de prise sur ces seniors
ils ont soixante soixante dix et même 80
ans et pratique karaté un sport aussi
bon pour la tête que pour les jambes
comme ils l'ont expliqué à nos confrères
de lmtv à sartre ouverte et puis pour
terminer ce premier journal de l'année
nous partirons à plusieurs milliers de
kilomètres de là au népal grâce à nos
confrères de 8 mont blanc qui nous
feront découvrir un alpiniste hors du
commun
voilà pour ce journal comme je vous le
disais dans les titres s'il ya un
secteur qui ne connaît pas la crise
c'est bien celui du jeu de société il
réalise chaque année une progression de
10% et parmi les grands acteurs de ce
secteur il y as gigamic une société
française basée dans le pas de calais où
nous emmène caroline fichten de wéo la
chaîne de la voix du nord regardez
la caverne du jeu c'est une adresse à
kelly qui commence à être connu et à se
faire une place ici on trouve tout type
de jeu du classique du rapide du jeu de
réflexion et quelles que soient les
goûts des joueurs tous apprécient le
côté collectif du jeu de société c'est
l'enthousiasmé populaire d'être ensemble
un petit peu le côté un peu compétitif
entre nîmes et même si c'est en 3
famille et entre amis tout ça avec la
famille le week-end essentiellement puis
des fois je trouve aussi des chevaux
pour ma fille donc
toujours un peu de tout
on sort de l'écran juste ça alors c'est
vrai il ya de quoi être perdu quand on
entre ici mais la force des magasins
spécialisés c'est leur connaissance des
jeux qu'ils ont en boutique le jeu de
société un peu dépoussiéré fonctionne
bien depuis une dizaine d'années et
encore davantage depuis les confinements
énormément de gens qui sont restés
enfermés chez eux avec des monopoly
défunt des jeux classiques et nous on a
apporté une fraîcheur dans notre société
grâce à tous nos différents
distributeurs notamment gigamic lots
asmodée mme lacrotte etc et les gens on
a envie de renouveler un petit peu leur
ludothèque en france tous les ans sort
entre 1500 et 2000 nouvelles références
l'un des éditeurs de jeux de société se
trouve dans la région à wimereux gigamic
existe depuis 30 ans l'entreprise reçoit
chaque année entre 800 et un millier d'
idée de jeu elle dans sélectionne une
dizaine seulement puis se chargent de
l'habillage du prototype on va s'occuper
de toute la recherche et développement
autour de ce prototype c'est à dire
qu'on va récupérer l'idée et on va en
faire après un jeu on va
chercher des illustrations peut-être
redémarre tease et retravailler
certaines mécanisme vraiment ciblé le
public et puis après tout ce qui est
logistique donc avec quels matériaux
dans quelle boîte ça va rentrer à quel
prix etc entre la présentation d'un
concept et sa sortie en boutique il faut
compter au moins 18 mois gigamic propose
beaucoup de jeu rapide accessible et
familiaux des jeux en partie pensée dans
la région donc
nous partons à présent à 60 km au nord
de bordeaux au clos de l'échauguette à
micro vignoble que nous fait découvrir
bénédicte doha de tv7 la chaîne du
groupe sud ouest c'est un lieu où vous
allez le voir chargé d'histoire
niché sur les hauteurs de la commune la
citadelle prise d'assaut par les
promeneurs abrite un vignoble unique en
france l'échauguette bien plus qu un
vignoble une plongée dans l'histoire dès
l'instant où on y pénètre qu'il faut
s'imaginer qu'à l'époque et si c'était
juste un petit tunnel creusé dans la
roche le là où se situe le vignoble
c'était une carrière de pierres et les
pierres étaient extraites de cet endroit
pour construire la citadelle voilà tant
qu'il n'avait absolument pas de vignes
et ce tunnel a été agrandi et aménagé
pour permettre aux machines viticoles de
passer
si la citadelle date du xviie siècle ce
n'est qu'en 1968 que le projet d'y
planter le tout premier vignoble de
collectif voit le jour
bienvenue dans le clos de l'échauguette
un micro vignoble d'exception d'à peine
15 ares qui appartient à l'ensemble des
vignerons de l'appellation blaye côtes
de bordeaux
737 pieds de vigne qui ont connu
quelques péripéties la première récolte
date de 1978 à l'époque en fête le vin
ne servait qu'à faire la promotion de
l'appellation il n'était pas
commercialisé
dans les années 90 ils se sont ils ont
décidé d'arracher en fait les vignes du
clos de l'échauguette parce que la
parcelle est dit tardives c'est-à-dire
que le raisin mettait trop de temps à
mûrir et à l'époque il y avait plusieurs
cépages il y avait du merlot et du
cabernet sauvignon notamment donc tout
est arraché tout est replanté avec une
mejia meilleure orientation et
aujourd'hui on a une parcelle qui est
100% au merlot c'est en 2013 que le clos
de l'échauguette se converti à
l'agriculture biologique il faudra
attendre trois ans avant de découvrir le
premier millésime bio du micro vignoble
on a voilà ce côté merlot qui qui domine
ce côté fruité et et un boisé qui n'est
pas trop dominants chaque année le
vignoble produit environ 600 bouteilles
une cuvée d'exception disponibles
uniquement à la maison du vin de blaye
ou sur internet
voilà puis c'est un cru exceptionnel à
consommer avec modération
autant pour sa santé que pour son
porte-monnaie puisque le prix d'une
bouteille tournent autour des 30 euros
tout de même voilà après la dinde et la
bûche voici la galette et comme je vous
le disais en titre celle qui a été
couronnée meilleure galette des yvelines
par la fédération de la boulangerie
pâtisserie se trouve à saint germain en
laye alors évidemment mitchell temeria
un santisteva de tv 78 s'y est rendu
pour nous regarder
[Musique]
c'est ici à la boulangerie du château de
saint-germain-en-laye que se trouve la
meilleure galette aux amandes des
yvelines édition 2022 elle est préparée
de bon matin par sébastien bouillet
[Musique]
j'ai fait quatre galettes et il fallait
les quatre galettes soit vraiment
l'identique mon avis j'ai vu d'eau de
galettes et je pense que c'est vraiment
la régularité j'avais une galette était
vraiment très très assez élevé mais en
même temps très plate et pas bomber la
galette qui fait 30 cm et la taille
requis pour le concours toute façon un
premier prix décerné pour une galette
travaillait avec précision il faut être
hyper minutieux et faut surtout pas trop
tranché le feuilletage après la cuisson
avec le développement du feuilletage on
voit apparaître le décor il ya même des
gens qui demandent des galettes des
parfums qu'on n'a pas forcément mais
c'est pas un problème parce que là bas
c'est toujours à peu près la même une
crème d'amande d'un feuilletage qui
compte c'est la régularité un maximum de
régularité le site en a un qui gros qui
est petit bain après c'est parti pour un
peu près une heure de cuisson à 170°
sébastien d'ailleurs remporté le
deuxième prix du meilleur salariés de
récompenses symboliques pour le gérant
michael fourché ça prouve que on est
dans le vrai on est on est vraiment dans
le sang pour sang fait maison c'est qui
est très important pour moi les gens
sont sensibles je pense aujourd'hui
à ce genre de concours aujourd'hui on
s'approprie un peu le boulanger on va
chez vous angers et c'est une fierté
pour moi et pour tous mes clients la
boulangerie est qualifié pour le
concours régional qu'elle connaît déjà
puisque son croissant avait terminé 2e
d'ile-de-france de galettes seront
envoyés pour être jugé entre le 4 et le
7 janvier
voilà dans ces temps un peu troublé il
faut bien le dire un peu de solidarité
cela fait chaud au coeur après ces fêtes
de fin d'année ben de causette c'est le
nom de ce dispositif n'est à
bain-de-bretagne une commune au sud de
rennes qui permet de briser la solitude
des seniors un sujet tout en douceur de
nos confrères de thé vert la chaîne de
rennes regardé
et m'a
filé vos héros
oui bah justement comme chaque semaine à
bain-de-bretagne agnès bénévoles rend
visite à yvette cette dernière a choisi
l'activité du jour jeux de société et
plaisanteries les deux femmes se sont
rencontrées grâce au dispositif 20 de
causette il ya seulement un an mais le
courant est tout de suite passé à
reyniès avait parlé de la famille met
nos chances de refaire la nuit tellement
je suis contente d'attendre ancienne
enseignante et habitante de
bain-de-bretagne yvette vit toujours
chez elle à bientôt 92 ans
la venue d'agnès lui offre une compagnie
bienvenus devenue sa complice est lui
rend visite tous les mardis et même
parfois à l'improviste et suite à une
maladie j'étais obligée d'abandonner mon
travail à 52 ans j'ai cogité dans ma
tête que si je remarche est genre été
voir les gens à domicile seul pour moi
c'était leur apporter de la chaleur
après un ralentissement dû aux qu'ovide
le dispositif a repris de plus belle à
la rentrée pas de critère d'âge il est
ouvert à tous les habitants de la
commune qui se sentent isolés et en
manifestent le besoin auprès du ccas les
binômes bénévoles bénéficiaires sont
ensuite ressortis avec soin il ya une
rencontre qui est fait avec le potentiel
bénéficiaire donc la potentielle
personnes visitées pour voir quelles
sont ses attentes qu'est ce qu'elle
souhaite faire comme visite selon le
dans la ville où comme je vois qu'à ce
qu'elle attend du réseau bonne cause est
compte actuellement sept binômes actif
mais reçoit régulièrement de nouvelles
demandes pour l'instant la plupart des
bénéficiaires sont des personnes âgées
mais le ccs est vrai que le dispositif
servent aussi à d'autres publics comme
de jeunes étudiants ou des parents
isolés
et puis solidarité toujours dans ce
journal avec cette belle histoire de
l'eac a 21 ans et qui vient d'ouvrir sa
boulangerie à sion les mines en loire
atlantique alors que les banques refusé
de lui prêter un centime deux anciens
boulangers sont venus à son secours
un conte de fées moderne que nous
raconte anaïs donnait de télénantes dans
la loire atlantique
elle est aux commandes de sa boulangerie
depuis trois semaines et ses pâtisseries
font déjà l'unanimité dans la communauté
donc je propose plein de gâteaux tous
les gâteaux à thème mignardises gâteaux
traditionnels
j'ai eu mon ca péan candidats j'ai
acheté mes livres et j'ai appris tout
seul le pin gris et un pinceau que ça
nous fait 4 euros s'il vous plaît quand
les boulangers de la commune bientôt en
retraite lui ont proposé de prendre la
suite les banques elles ont dit non le
manque d'expérience en milieu
professionnel encore et où je voyais le
fait que je sois une femme et que j'ai
21 ans et vit mais franck les anciens
boulangers m'ont proposé un crédit
vendeur que j'ai accepté c'était
totalement inespéré sans ça je n'aurais
pas pu reprendre la volant à l'arrière
de la boulangerie franck est encore là
pour accompagner les ah oui ma femme a
pris sa retraite et puis moi j'ai encore
trois ans à faire et puis ça nous c'est
le challenge du moment maintenant on a
plus qu'à s'il retrouvait un boulanger
ça nous fait plaisir de voir l'homme la
succession à vous qui les a peut aussi
compter sur vincent son associé un
ancien agriculteur habitant de la
commune qui a décidé d'apporter des
fonds avec le maire de la commune on a
discuté et il est prévu que la
boulangerie narrer porn le café avait
déjà un peu arrêté il est repris des
fois il faut pas grand chose pour que
encore un tissu qui reste j'irai qu'il
reste vivant même et je me suis investi
je me dis des fois on les cas certains
capitaux sont aussi mia fait à
travailler dans une commune qui commune
pour faire vibrer comme
et puis bon après moi je me retire quand
à pouvoir voler de ses propres ailes
puis voilà j'aurais peut-être fait une
bonne chose un meunier du secteur a lui
aussi décidé d'aider les a
financièrement en échange elle utilise
sa farine pour les pins voilà ça y est
vous allez voir dans ce reportage on a
trouvé la fontaine de jouvence il s'agit
d'un sport le karaté et comme je vous
disais en titre enzo maubert de lmtv
sarthe a rencontré des octogénaires
ceinture noire de cette discipline est
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que c'est un
sport qui est bon pour le corps qui est
bon pour le coeur et qui est bon pour
l'esprit la preuve en images
ne vous fiez pas à leur âge ils ont beau
avoir entre 60 et 90 ans se sont pour
certains des karatékas
expérimenté
au dojo du club samouraï 2000 au mans
des séances sont spécialement réservée
aux seniors qu'ils soient ceinture noire
ou débutants secours il est fait pour
toutes les personnes qui sont rentrées
dans les arts martiaux mais pour
l'essence des arts martiaux c'est à dire
se préserver se préserver pas d'une
attaque extérieure parce qu'aujourd'hui
on va pas se faire attaquer dehors
normalement mais plutôt de la maladie et
de l'âge et l'âge n'a pas arrêté celui
qu'on appelle des des plus de 40 ans de
karaté à son compteur et c'est pour lui
un véritable remède c'est comme la pomme
le matin
la pomme le matin quand on dit je mange
une pomme le matin je mets moi se rend
chez le médecin et c'est pour ça que je
disais quand on fait du karaté
si le karaté fait travailler réflexe
concentration et mouvements il permet
aussi de créer du lien et de garder le
moral
ça permet justement d'éviter de
s'enraciner de s'encroûter on va dire
que c'est très convivial on souhaite
nous anniversaire on est à la limite on
est une petite bande d'amis
même des fonds fait participer nos
épouses donc c'est génial s'il vous de
l'ex aide aussi à vivre a donné un
mental dans la vie c'est pas toujours
facile quelques fois on tombe dans des
trous et ses 184 on a déjà connu la
maladie etc l'hospitalisation mais ça
aide à se relever à chaque fois et c'est
ça qui est important pour moi bien plus
qu'un sport de défense fouler le tatami
peut donc éviter non pas de vieillir
mais de devenir vieux
voilà et puis maintenant dans ce journal
je vous propose de découvrir ou de
redécouvrir un accessoire de mode qui
nous vient de martinique le marais tête
qui se nouent d'une façon bien
particulière
explications de tome gagne ou de via à
tv qui s'est rendu dans l'atelier des
manuels soudja tu as une styliste qui
l'a remis au goût du jour regarder
nous et le marais tête c'est un geste
vieux comme le monde la pratique est née
sur les berges du mississippi en
louisiane en 1785 une loi impose aux
femmes de couleur de couvrir leurs
cheveux en réponse à l'asservissement
les affranchis transforme le foulard en
accessoires de beauté
aujourd'hui le marais tête est un
véritable accessoire de mode colorée de
différentes formes ils se re visite
selon les tendances l'art de nouer le
tissu lui n'a pas changé emmanuel le
pratiquent au quotidien dans son atelier
c'est le modèle de la bamboche kg en
fait de superposition de tissus et dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de noeud est en
fait les plis permet d'après au tissu de
rester bien stable qu'en fait le marais
tête est antérieure à la coiffe
traditionnelle qui a été porté pendant
longtemps avec la robe à la robe créole
en savoir faire traditionnels qui
fascine depuis toujours la styliste
bamboche pain de sucre et autres coiffes
autant d'expressions de cet art qui
repose avant tout sur le new age voilà
plusieurs années qu emmanuel s'attache à
rendre au marais tête ses lettres de
noblesse qui sont inscrits dans
l'artisanat d'art parc fasse partie de
notre patrimoine culturel
et puis que les autres générations à
venir aussi continuer à la porter
[Musique]
pour promouvoir son travail emmanuel
fait régulièrement des shootings photos
l'occasion pour elle d' essayer de
peaufiner ses créations les photos sont
publiées sur les réseaux sociaux seul
réel support que j'ai pour faire
connaître mon travail après
effectivement plus je travaille que je
vais faire des photos plus jéhovah ce
qui va ce qu'on va passer à améliorer ou
pas - encore rim a nié le monsieur amar
et tête je me sens vraiment valorisé
belle là je suis belle mais là dessus je
le suis encore plus avec le mari tête et
voilà c'est quelque chose d unique et
c'est un patrimoine à
la styliste donne également des cours
dans lesquels elle enseigne les
techniques de nos âges pour un parfait
marais tête elle vous attend dans son
atelier à fort de france
voilà vous avez encore le temps de
prendre de bonnes résolutions ce début
d'année alors pourquoi ne pas apprendre
à naviguer d'une manière particulière
quand même franc que tammy fans de voile
a mis son savoir faire et son expérience
à la portée de tous en créant un outil
numérique que nous présente valérie
leroux colonie de tébéo la chaîne du
groupe le télégramme un outil aussi
ingénieux que facile d'utilisation
regarder
franck navigue depuis 17 ans et comme
tous les voileux moi j'ai commencé à
apprendre soit en partageant des
pratiques avec des collègues ou même des
écoles de croisière mais mixé à des
bouquins je suis rendu compte de la
longueur un an dans l'apprentissage
alors ce fameux de mails spécialiste en
apprentissage du méric décide d'inventer
son outil d'aidé à la navigation idéales
on n'est pas en train de dire jeter vos
livres au contraire on vient apporter je
dirais quelque chose de complémentaire
avec comme matière première la vidéo
qu'on projette tout de suite l'individu
dans la situation c'est pour ça qu'on
apprend beaucoup plus vite pour y
accéder sur le site le navigateur choisi
son niveau ainsi que son type
d'embarcation leur mission faciliter la
compréhension des manoeuvres techniques
grâce à une mise en image très
pédagogique il conseillait de convenir
d'un langage de signes entre l'équipier
à l'encré et le barreur avant de larguer
les amarres l'équipage peut ainsi répété
ses manoeuvres à terre et en famille
pourquoi pas avant de s'assurer que
chacun à bord connaissons rouge commence
à rencontrer des personnes et nous
disait armé merci c'est la première fois
que je navigue avec ma femme depuis des
années où on ne s'engueule pas un
contenu valide et donc par les couples
mais aussi par plusieurs skippers
professionnels comme elle peut prés
télécharger des vidéos pour pouvoir les
regarder rohmer sans avoir de connexion
internet mais aussi des fiches de
synthèse qui sont imprimables la
plateforme et l'application sont
aujourd'hui plébiscités pas la snsm
certaines marques d'équipements
nautiques les écoles de croisière et
certains ports aussi va pouvoir donner
les supports de ce type à l'ensemble des
usagers pour qu'ils pratiquent mieux les
sorties et les entrées lutter a aussi
contre tous ces bateaux qui ne bougent
plus par peur une représentation de
personnes qui n'ont pas pratiqué depuis
des années prochain challenge en cours
pour l'équipe bretonne conquérir à
l'international la plateforme est en
cours de traduction pour un premier
client une école de voile au canada
voilà on reste en bretagne à la
rencontre d'un menuisier à la retraite
qui s'est découvert une étonnante et
très jolie passion il ya trois ans il a
donc invité natacha stores de thé vert à
découvrir ce qu'il a créé son village
miniature
regardez ce reportage
tout est parti d'un cadeau il y a trois
ans jacky reçoit un train à rails et il
était loin d'imaginer qu'il fabriquait
un village entier miniatures
son église une poste voilà ici bars
restaurants hôtels
des petits joueurs de boules la garde
barrière et là un village devenu
rapidement histoire de famille bienvenue
à celle mia un nom qui reprend les
initiales des six petits fils du
retraité j'ai que mes petits enfants ils
viennent la première chose papilles le
train ils et comment il finit on peut
aller voir mais j'y vais ou venez voir
l'or donc ils sont là l'aînée va payer à
10 ans commence à prendre un petit peu
les manettes pour les faire pour le
faire marcher ces presque cinq mètres
carrés représente 2000 heures de travail
dans son atelier du sable du carton des
boîtes d'oeufs ou encore détails le
menuisier de profession trouvent une
seconde vie à de nombreux objets
quotidiens pour égayer le chemin de fer
donc je me suis dit fois je fasse
quelque chose alors pas un petit village
peut-être et puis après j'ai dit
pourquoi pas refaire une rivière après
pourquoi pas mettre à châteauroux et
caen je suis un ancien menuisier
pourquoi pas faire une série je dirais
qu'il ya deux mois voilà ce faire un
truc qui ils pourraient vivre ces lignes
a et son château son viaduc et ses
voitures d'époque
d'ici peu le village s'agrandira d'un
mètre cinquante pour accueillir une
vallée parsemé de moutons de quoi faire
perdurer encore un peu la magie de cette
bourgade miniature à vitré
et puis je vous propose d'aller à la
rencontre des champions de demain grâce
à jean marc lucas qui a assisté aux
entraînements de kayakistes en vue des
jeux olympiques de paris 2024 regardez
il existe quatre pôles d'excellence
dédié au canoë-kayak en france dont un
basé à toulouse ici les meilleurs
sportifs de la fédération s'entraîne
pour les championnats du monde ou encore
les jeux olympiques les athlètes
s'adonnent à leur sport entre 15 et 25
heures par semaine
mais avant de ram et il faut se muscler
et pas uniquement les bras sur la
stabilité on est beaucoup sur les jambes
et les abdos sur la propulsion on est
vraiment sur le haut du corps mais faut
vraiment du gainage pour faire avancer
le bateau donc l'idée c'est d'avoir un
corps bien développée pour pour prévenir
les blessures pour développer un magret
puissance le kayak compte plusieurs
disciplines le slalom le marathon ou
encore les descentes la france est une
surface dans cette catégorie et à
toulouse nous avons un champion d'europe
il a 26 ans et ils disent les sommets
mon objectif plein sens en 2022 on a les
chauffeurs du monde de descente des
rivières qui sont à trignac en france
c'est la rivière qui est mythique je
connais le moindre caillou de l'ariège
autant connaître chaque caillou chaque
vague et après j'envisage oui
potentiellement d'aller me confronter à
au milieu olympique pour paris du 24
voire los angeles 2028 une autre
discipline existe c'est la course en
ligne sur du plat les cadettes et les
juniors du sprint ont un cursus au lycée
un spécialement aménagée au creps de
toulouse - jongler entre les salles de
classe et les entraînements sur la
garonne
et ces futures championnes savent
défendre leur sport que je pense
l'ambiance le sport de nature le toucher
l'eau tout ça c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment cool la france compte cinquante
mille licenciés en canoë kayak et pour
l'élite en 2024 aux jo de paris
l'objectif est de rafler toutes les
médailles
et puis nous terminons ce journal par
une grande bouffée d'oxygène nous allons
prendre de la hauteur puisque je vous
emmène à plus de 8000 mètres d'altitude
emmanuel jo de 8 mont blanc nous
présente jean michel jorda alpinistes
réalisateur est amoureux fou de
l'everest au népal
la pollution sur les plus hauts sommets
questionne de nombreux montagnards
partout sur la planète et parmi eux le
réalisateur et documentariste jean
michel jordan fort de sa dernière
production nommée everest green et
plusieurs fois primé dans différents
festivals il a choisi de prolonger son
enquête pour s'intéresser à la gestion
des déchets en altitude est vrai ce
green c'est un constat c'est un constat
de 15 ans de cheminement sur les
montagnes himalayennes et avec grèce
green j'ai voulu faire un document qui
disait voilà on étoiles l'everest depuis
une vingtaine d'années je vois la vallée
de katmandou et dans cette vallée la
vraie ce green disait que voilà veut
depuis 20 ans on laisse aller 500 tonnes
de déchets par jour
dans les rivières polluants
les rivières l'eau les sols un vrai
problème qui va bien au-delà de la seule
gestion des camps d'altitude et des
expéditions commerciales pour autant
petit à petit certains népalais commence
à mieux saisir les enjeux et lance avec
leurs moyens des pistes pour faire
évoluer la situation des acteurs locaux
qu'a rencontré le réalisateur
ce que j'aime faire en fait dans lorsque
je fais un documentaire et everest
recycling sera dans cette mouvance là
c'est semer des idées et si ses idées
elle fonctionne s'il y en a qui trouvent
que y ait cette idée est bonne je trouve
que c'est bon et allégeance ils ont eu
envie de faire des choses
eh ben on va parler d'eux après une
première phase de tournage entre
katmandou et le parc du makalu jeu
michel jorda retournera sur les pentes
de l'everest au printemps prochain pour
continuer de documenter son prochain
film une production qui devrait voir le
jour d'ici l'horizon 2022
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand jt des
territoires merci de l'avoir suivi sur
vos chaînes locales et régionales et sur
tv5 monde on se retrouve très vite pour
une prochaine édition aura tous
[Musique]